wenn es nach carl hirschmann ginge
würden sie diesen film nicht sehen
vergangene woche verurteilte ihn das
bezirksgericht zürich erstinstanzlich
als sexual und gewalttäter er verfolge
die befriedigung der eigenen wünsche
zielstrebig notfalls auch rücksichtslos
und ohne empathie für die opfer so der
gerichtspräsident
das urteil ist noch nicht rechtskräftig
fest steht indes seither wünscht der 31
jährige multimillionär keine politik
mehr vor seinem prozess war er auf einer
porsche fahrt durchs nächtliche zürich
noch gespräche
daniel will ich den berg
[Musik]
ich sagte ihm überwältigt werden
die witzige nötigen
schlecht behandelt werde aber sie
wollten ja in welchem ist bin ich sechs
oder sag ich mal
und was was frau
überlegt werde dass das mal wieso
kontrolle übernehmen
300 rock-
und popmusik auf
beklagt und lag zu mittag
es habe ich eigentlich weiß ich ob so
absolut absurd und auch das gibt es
nicht die kakaomasse klar es gibt nur
statistisch gesehen das war schon blut
natürlich usa- und redet gut bedient und
dann entsteht positive dynamik wo er
immer das erhöht das die was passiert
okay
die
bibliothek und nicht einfach die slawen
ende 2010 nachdem er wiederholt in u
haft gesetzt wurde diverse verfahren
gegen ihn laufen und sein vater
gestorben ist will carl hirschmann nur
noch weg
zusammen mit einer handvoll freunden und
dem starfotografen michael greis der im
privatjet richtung osten
laut hirschmann ein lebensverändernde
einmonatiger selbstfindungstrip
[Musik]
sehr viel ein sammeltaxi also ich hatte
glück sie war sehr viel blut und für
sehr viele sachen aber ich habe
eigentlich
alle bilder nicht gemacht wo ihm sind
extrem einsam sie und serizit gelogen
[Musik]
immer mit dabei michel comte den er für
die ferien bilder engagiert hat und ein
kameramann der hirschmanns reise zu sich
selbst dokumentiert am ende entsteht
daraus ein 90 minütiger film für sein
privatarchiv kostenpunkt unbekannt
[Musik]
weiter nach kambodscha hirschmann will
sich künftig für minenopfer engagieren
das
und schließlich momente der stille in
angkor wat
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sony versucht und fx
everything
was ich interessant wie nie ich mache
ein foto und ich brauche jetzt einen
film dass es
fähig sind sie völlig findet vielleicht
sind es auch künftig kollers ins lounges
ins hotel hotel auf der waldbauer weiß
was luxus ist
was los
vielleicht kann er in zukunft erschweren
das motto
stand am ende das würde ich im kölner
miller hat gut geschmeckt hatte
gottschalk hat sehr gut gespielt und
sehr sehr sensibel da sind ja so fein
ist wie mir weh mir ali
[Musik]
mit anfang 20 scheint hirschmann später
erbe von mutmaßlich mehreren hundert
millionen seine berufung gefunden zu
haben nach der matura machte er sein
hobby den ausgang zum beruf der wirt
partyveranstalter
[Musik]
völlig bvb-coach gegensatz zu einer
bundesweit tätigen und das machen wie
ich sie waren die mails was auch immer
von
vorteil oder
im ersten gang 18 geburtstag hat mir
extrem viel es bedeutet
und ich habe mich gefreut dass er das so
gar nicht
drum vorstelle kauf von 80 geburtstag
und so und hofft dass mein vater
da ich mir
voller emotionen her ich mir seit
da möchte ich meinen sohn immer möglich
spezielles machen so und leider viele
maschinen philipp burkhardt und
ich nachher schlussendlich für mich dass
der geburtstag eines schlimmen
hochwasser
damit ihm das nicht mehr passiert
organisiert er seine partys von da an
selber und eröffnet an der bahnhofstraße
2007 gar einen eigenen klub dass sammer
[Musik]
die schweizer prominenz gibt sich ein
stelldichein für den 26 jährigen enkel
des gleichnamigen gründers des
milliarden unternehmens jet aviation
[Musik]
rund vier millionen franken hat carl
hirschmann in diesen klub an bester lage
investiert
[Musik]
plötzlich steht er im zentrum des
interesses in diesem falle eines
ausgangs magazins eines regional
fernsehsenders
jetzt ist er der manager der nach
eigenen angaben mit einem enormen
zuneigung und aufmerksamkeit defizit von
seiten der eltern aufgewachsen ist und
als jugendlicher ein außenseiter war
jetzt wollen alle etwas von ihm ein
interview gratis drinks oder ihm einfach
nur auf die schultern klopfen eine
lebensschule sagte er
[Musik]
ein verein muss ich über mein schon weiß
nicht 8 leberkrebs und
das feld sehr lang gezogen zum das zum
das beantworten aber
[Applaus]
jedem das ist ja okay so wählen wie lose
gesellschaft oder so
[Musik]
es wird viel mehr gelogen als
erst mal so
ich ehrlich sagen so der mensch
ich sie am saubersten und egal was lief
erzählt und egal was das liebe und
freundschaft und ausdauer man meint man
sich entscheiden muss dann wird der
[Musik]
schulband
die zum tafel stein ich sagen und die
frau zum teil an und sagte mir dass ich
das
das ganze ist in rom wo er unter das was
man wann frau in einer leistung findet
und ich mir hundert lügen und blieb vor
dem die bergfreunde ist völlig oder
völlig im sinn foto hatten wieder frost
oder verletzt oder dass das dass das
frauen dann irgendwie umso medienwandel
höchste werden typisch
[Musik]
hirschmann genießt sein leben in vollen
zügen und mit vielen kollateralschäden
[Musik]
die medien bejubeln ihn dafür dass er an
der seite internationaler superstar das
zelebriert was die popkultur einer
ganzen generation als ultimativen
lebenstraum suggeriert den reinen
hedonismus
[Musik]
carl hirschmann auf dem höhepunkt
die vor uns stehen schlange in der
hoffnung auf die große liebe oder einen
kick oder mediale aufmerksamkeit oder
sozialen aufstieg oder alles zusammen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit frau extrem schön
[Musik]
moralisch gesehen durchaus steinig so
habt ihr abo zu folge ins prozentig
bezieht sie ruft betrüge das muss ich
einfach sagen und ich kotzen teil mit
frau spielt mit emotionen die hause
würde für mich polter und dann noch
nicht einige male lieferzeit wo sie
entweder chöre und so weiter und so fort
okay und das muss ich darf mich zu
bringen ihre micro pixel und das mache
ich ja nicht so dass dies ganz ehrlich
und klarheit aber es hat natürlich ist
wie game und nicht so 67 und ansporn
dass die frau wegen mir mich verwöhnt
und dann auch nicht mich geschichte
verwickelt und gelogen und geachtet dass
das sicher zur betreibers dass das dass
das auch wie
negative emotionen start was ich mir
immer gemacht und nehmen auch wer frau
schwan verletze oder irgendwie sexuell
misshandelt oder zu zwingen
genau solche vorwürfe stehen aber bald
im raum nicht mehr nur gebrochene herzen
sondern eine gebrochene nase im basler
klub nun soll hirschmann eine frau die
ihm einen korb gegeben habe die uhr
folgt haben als ihr freund dazwischen
gegangen sei habe er diesem die nase
gebrochen das strafgericht basel stadt
spricht hirschmann ende 2009 schuldig
das urteil wird aber nie rechtskräftig
weil sich die parteien auf einen
vergleich einigen
dennoch der tiefe fall des carl
hirschmann ist nicht mehr aufzuhalten
die dunkle seite des verführers wird den
medien jetzt von seinen sogenannten
freunden die ihm bisher auf die
schultern klopfen in blumigen
einzelheiten geschildert eine bekannte
behauptet zum beispiel ich habe erfahren
dass in diesem raum waren blowjob orgien
stattfanden karli sich vor gästen und
djs einen blasen hirschmann bestreitet
dies carl hirschmann das und express
gesagt ziele nicht erfüllt zu sagen was
eigentlich frau und kind es müssen viele
sagen das müsst ihr sexualpraktiken
andere
und eine ex gespielin behauptet karl hat
zwei gesichter das charmante und das
hässliche brutale das kam oft im
versteckten zum vorschein wenn er den
platinum room abschloss wurde es für die
mädchen gefährlich hirschmann bestreitet
auch dies ist gerade erst mal ein
notorischer schläger und einer der
frauen misshandelt oder nur ein heißes
blut mit leidenschaftlichen affären
es sei ein drama mit ankündigung gewesen
schreiben jetzt die die ihn vorher hoch
gejubelt haben sicher ist es ist eine
mediale exekution welche der presserat
später kritisieren und die journalisten
zur mäßigung aufgerufen wird wenn vieles
stellt sich im nachhinein als frei
erfunden heraus oder die parteien
einigen sich außergerichtlich zum inhalt
der vergleiche und allfälligen zahlungen
gibt hirschmann keine auskunft
das mini
überhaupt so
generiert hatte scheint es als
armutszeugnis ganz eng für
presselandschaft opera für für glaser
wenn ich also sorry was was was hat was
hat in carl hirschmann für für ihre
relevanz
gesamtschweizerisch
sind absolut keine für die hsg hatte
ende 2010 offenbar diese relevanz der
dialog club lehtinen zu einer
podiumsdiskussion ein hier gibt das who
is who der schweizer wirtschaft sein
wissen an den nachwuchs weiter von
daniel vasella über peter kurer bis
peter brabeck
und jetzt carl hirschmann der sein hsg
studium schon nach einem semester wieder
abgebrochen hat und seinen klub als bald
schließen will aber den saal trotzdem
spielen füllt
die angehende wirtschaftsingenieur seine
expertise als unternehmer sondern allen
negativen schlagzeilen zum trotz auf
seinen rat als playboy
mit
[Musik]
was gerne frauen dass das merkt man und
das hört man und was tust du und dann um
in den augen der frauen attraktiv zu
erscheinen
ich glaube
man oder frau es ist immer das gleiche
jetzt muss es muss einfach glaubwürdig
sein aber sonst wenn man zu viel
überlegt und gefallen will dann erreicht
man meistens das gegenteil
natürlich meine frau weiß dass sie ein
und entwickelt hat dann verliert der
verliert sich bereits für sie also ist
sie
[Musik]
cool ness oder wie man das dass das eine
roadshow mit schlachtgewichte die stolz
dass das dass das ist nicht schlecht und
was wichtig ist wie
schnell greifen danke dass das frauen
auch im
airbus fordert wird und dann in
kombination also wenn eine
nummerierung desinteressierten
kreisstadt
[Musik]
das wird jetzt für das video läuft seit
ich hier zufrieden
[Musik]
doch die vergangenheit holt ihn ein in
form einer 15 seitigen anklageschrift
seine verhandlung vor dem zürcher
bezirksgericht vergangene woche gerät zu
einer niederlage auf der ganzen linie
ganz entgegen seinen erwartungen vor dem
prozess war
jeder einzelne von ihnen gleich zwei
einzeln betrachtet ich forscht
verstorbene die mir zurückholen exotik
stellt wer die prämie aber zu mir ich
noch das ist fragwürdig wird verstauen
nicht akzeptiere ich nicht stehe nicht
allein aber jeder fall einzeln
betrachtet ist eigentlich fast
komödie die erste instanz befindet erste
verurteilung sexuelle nötigung eine
gleichaltrige frau die er aus seiner
jugendzeit in küssnacht kannte habe er
2005 an einer party im nachtclub
diagonal in eine enge toilette gelockt
dort habe er ihr sein erigiertes glied
in den mund gedrückt und bis zum
orgasmus hin und herbewegt anschließend
habe er ihr den mund zugehalten und sie
damit gezwungen das ejakulat herunter zu
schlucken
[Musik]
zweite verurteilung sexuelle nötigung
und körperverletzung
2008 habe er einer 24 jährigen auf der
terrasse seines clubs sei ebenfalls sein
glied in den mund gedrückt als sie ihn
in sein geschlechtsteil gebissen habe
habe er ihr einen faustschlag auf die
nase versetzt anschließend habe er
weiter auf sie eingeprügelt
ich bin schon mehrmals leiter hintergeht
xi und versuchen nicht gemacht haben
also jetzt
ja das paar in untersuchungshaft sie und
hollage verhältnis unterwegs auf zuzug
lang ist das sind zwei paar schuhe will
kann dies über schweiz sind sind sehr
gut strukturiert mache meinen job hat
ramsauer koscher je nachdem was er
angestellt hat und und
ich verstehe das des voyeurismus und
schaut erfreut
dass keine sich vorstellen wie der
schweizer den hoch und
es ist ja schon passiert ich bin schockt
für das wohl nicht gemacht haben also
ich weiß ganz genau weiß ich das auf und
ich will
könnte ein umfallen ist beibrachte und
sachsen reha machen und sagt manager
hatten vor allem in mini rocker gibt mir
die nächste regierung schmerzen viel
musik für community ist klang musik
ich habe mir das tricks nicht dritter
verurteilung sexuelle handlungen mit
kindern
2010 habe er sich bei diversen
gelegenheiten oral befriedigen lassen
von einer 15 jährigen und deren
volljährige freundin er habe sich nach
dem alter der 15-jährigen erkundigt und
diese habe ihm die falsche auskunft
gegeben
sie sei schon 17 womit sich hirschmann
zufrieden gegeben habe vor gericht
gesteht er sein fahrlässiges handeln ein
er hätte kritischere fragen bezüglich
ihres wahren alters stellen müssen
vierter anklagepunkt körperverletzung
nötigung tätigkeiten die zürcher justiz
erklärt sich bei den meisten dieser
delikte für nicht zuständig weil sich im
ausland ereignet haben sollen der
staatsanwalt fordert 44 monate haft für
hirschmann der die meisten vorwürfe
vehement bestreitet
das bezirksgericht zürich verurteilte
hirschmann zu 33 monaten haft eine
genugtuung für den staatsanwalt zwar
sind 19 monate auf bewährung aber 14
monate muss hirschmann absitzen falls
das urteil rechtskräftig wird ich bin
vor haben sie darüber dass redet
überhaupt auch angepumpt verurteilt
worden ist dass man den opfern gehabt
hat als
strafbare sich bei exakt die
wissenschaft und das gericht hat er sich
sehr gut und genau geortet und
wichtig ist dass er doch ein rechter
teil von der strafe verbüßte müssen für
ökonomie und vermutlich dass er echte
belastungen 14 gekommen inhalt
verschafft wird
[Musik]
und so endet diese geschichte mit einer
versteinerten mienen und
damit dass carl hirschmann dem schweizer
fernsehen für keine weiteren aufnahmen
zur verfügung steht
das gibt